you
you
I'm Pam Sally I'm from Philadelphia ish
have been there a few years now and I do
stuff I always like to put on my bio I
just make things on the internet but
especially in philadelphia i am known
for running around a bunch of various
communities involved in the Ruby
community and the Python community and I
teach and I've taught Ruby Python
JavaScript web development get and I
usually do that in low cost either free
or low-cost environments half the time
knock any pain and sometimes getting
paid a little bit so what I want to talk
about today is some of the existing
education programs that are in other
communities that I think the JavaScript
beanie really needs to learn from why
particularly the JavaScript community
has a very special problem that we need
to use education as a solution and how
we can how we have in Philadelphia use
education in our community so who's been
teaching so have any of you guys heard
of some of these were initiatives before
I hope yeah I hoped most of you because
they're really great things I've taught
for a few of them but my favorite
personal favorite biased I love the
Boston Python workshop because the
Boston fight that workshop is based in a
user group and they have these really
great results from the particular way
that they do things the other ones
actually so rails girls railsbridge pi
star and actually the Boston Python
workshop also follow us a two-day format
where you have one day where people get
ready the next day where there's a
workshop that kind of format but Boston
Python workshop is attached particularly
to a user group so that's what we do in
Philadelphia in the Philadelphia Python
user group and so Boston Python when
they started the workshop they had zero
representation of women they increased
it to fifteen percent lots of alumni and
same growth and if you want to learn
more about it they did a great talk last
year at PyCon about a lot of lessons
learned a lot more details about how
exactly they did it so why does
javascript need to so javascript is a
special snowflake oh
so javascript has the unique and totally
awesome and problematic thing where
anyone who does anything on the internet
really should probably know JavaScript
or they try to or act like they do so
it's number one language in the world
and so we have this unique kind of thing
where we have all these people who have
dabbled in a little bit of JavaScript
and they've picked up enough enough to
do what they need to do but they really
don't have a deep understanding or even
a shallow understanding a lot of the
fundamentals so when we talk about
teaching javascript to people we have a
unique thing that happens is if I'm
teaching Python to a beginner they
chances are pretty high that they will
have zero programming experience if
they're coming to an intro to Python
workshop if I'm teaching an intro to
java script workshop a lot of times I
get much more people more people who are
already actually software engineers who
just know that they don't know any
JavaScript but they've had to pretend
like they do or people who have just
kind of fallen into it because you start
writing HTML you start writing the CSS
and then at some point you you know you
want to have like a log in modal so you
have to write JavaScript so how we can
do this is by putting education in our
user groups and that's the lime in the
coconut if you all get that joke anyway
so my top three reasons that you should
bring education to your user group
number one bring in new faces if we
learn something from Boston python is a
ridiculous weight up your numbers just
by hosting the workshop itself you get a
lot more than the people who join for
the workshop it's that kind of Awesome
network effect and the kind of you do
good things and good things happen to
you improve diversity so by making
things open and accessible and being the
kind of place that beginners can go you
essentially make things better for
everyone which kind of has a natural
diversity impact where you invite more
people who don't look like your standard
user group and then you get a user group
that looks like more like the rest of
the world hopefully and we want to make
JavaScript errs better right so since
code is read a lot more than it's
written my kind
of dream is that by educating all these
JavaScript errs to stop doing the things
that I hate seeing when I read someone
else's JavaScript that one day I'll
never have to read that again so we make
JavaScript better by making JavaScript
ders better and we started a kind of a
grassroots initiative to generally raise
code quality in general so I feel like
we're like generally is like in tech
community we're always interested in the
bleeding edge of things but I'm really
passionate about stepping back and
moving towards the lower level of things
and helping everyone else get themselves
up to more of an intermediate level and
there are also totally possibly selfish
reasons that you should bring education
to your user group you can use it to
attract sponsors good will bring us good
well we've noticed that when we do
things like bring education our user
group people start throwing money at us
we are not against that so we happily
use it to run more workshops or to bring
speakers from out of town or other happy
things like that you can also run
education programs outside your user
group such as for your interns I'm a big
fan of intern indoctrination that never
ever assume that your intern to know
something running intro workshops for
them I have explained the box model
countless times to people and I'm
morning same thing for that don't assume
things be honest and sincere in what
you're teaching learning lunchtime
courses for people who are rescaling
from another skill set that kind of
thing so you can bring education this
kind of education program doesn't have
to be in a user group so you can also do
it in other context to and teaching
makes you better and stuff teaching
challenges you I've been asked really
interesting questions by people who
didn't know that they were asking an
unusual question that kind of thing like
kind of like deep typing questions can I
do this does this work what happens if I
do that why does that have work that way
things like that that really kind of
happened when you start teaching and
also the side benefit of it you talk in
front of people and you're you know most
people can use to stand to get better at
that so how we did it in Philadelphia
and that was this is the workshop we
just did
a few weeks ago it was in at church
isn't that cool um so it's actually an
SEO firm that we did a church in philly
and so they have the search church
upstairs that they let us and other
groups use for events sometimes so we
had our workshop in the sanctuary so so
how are kind of how to do run a workshop
so running through these so promote from
within so while yes it can bring in new
members remember that the other goal is
to make everyone better we have a lot of
members of our user group who identify
as beginners or they identify as people
who are retooling and so making sure you
invite them first and that they you tell
them that their priority attendees
because you the reason is because you
want them to get more out of your user
group and so that say they can
understand more of the talks and they're
more interesting to them because they're
more relevant to them so promoting from
within is a really key point advertise
with your curriculum number one part of
that is advertised I've never had a
problem with selling out workshops of
any kind but I also have been told that
I'm very good at getting the word out
about things by putting up your
curriculum and saying what you're going
to cover especially in JavaScript so
that people know that you aren't going
to talk about Java is generally a good
idea so we advertise with our curriculum
available at least the syllabus of sorts
bring a friend strategy we really like
this to help that kind of like spreading
the network effects so that we say hey
members of the user group if you aren't
interested in if you know we're doing
this workshop thing and you're totally
awesome at javascript but I bet you know
someone at work who totally isn't you
totally shouldn't say that to them but
you should totally invite them to this
workshop and you should say all you know
volunteer so this is how you also get
people who are the great javascript in
your user group already you leverage
them as mentors and coaches my favorite
ratio is one mentor coach 25 students
using the word mentor coach you can also
say teaching assistant I kind of like
coach because it implies like kind of
like going for the team
kind of thing so I kind of call them
coaches it's my friend on laser corner
yeah as my friend Kelly he like blinks
during every picture it's really funny
and some of you all might know Val head
who just moved to Philly but i really
love mentors and coaches you really
can't run any workshop without them they
are so so super important because they
are the people so if I'm talking up here
and doing the lecture type thing and if
you guys went to there was that um the
strap of my guys doing their little one
of their micro talks with the teaching
thing they mentioned about how no one
likes to raise their hand which is
pretty really true and so that's why you
really kind of have to lean on your
coaches as being the people who are
wandering around the room who are being
accessible to the people who are looking
kind of confused and then your coach
says hey do you have any questions that
I can help with and it really works
really well charge your own money or
don't so I love free workshops I love
free workshops but problem is if you
give away something for free a lot of
times people just bail and the problem
with that with offering a low-cost
educational opportunity that's kind of a
kind of a rare thing and it's a really
important thing and so it's an
opportunity you want people to take
advantage of so we charge a little money
just to add that kind of like little
hurdle so that's like you have to give
us five dollars just so you prove that
you were willing to give us five dollars
and then we'll just use it for food and
the policy is very clear that if for any
reason you don't have to tell like when
I'm organizing workshop you don't have
to tell me any reason that you don't
want to pay you just have to email me
and say hey Pam I want to do the
workshop but I'm not giving you five
dollars and I'm like yeah cool and then
I'll find them up so we personally in
the Philadelphia JavaScript developers
group we charge a little money just to
provide that hurdle but also provide a
path so that if for whatever reason it's
a hardship it doesn't matter to me why
just providing a way for them to get
into the workshop set clear expectations
on all sides make sure your students
know what they're getting into make sure
they know they aren't going to a Jaffa
course and also that makes sure that you
let people know if if you do want to go
into some more advanced topics so you
don't get people who are overwhelmed so
you make sure that they're pointed
toward the more beginner side and you
also do this kind of expectations deal
free
coaches so making sure for one that your
coaches are skilled enough that they'll
be able to answer student questions
because I have had people in other
workshops try and sneak into workshops
by volunteering as a coach and it's
really not very good because then they
actually can't help because they really
should be a student it's great that they
love our workshops so much that they
want to like sneak in but not really
awesome for us on the organizer side but
for the coaches also setting clear
expectations like I always do a little
spiel about the rules of being a coach
like never touch someone else's computer
without asking so you respect people
space things like that and just making
sure that your coaches are on board with
what's going to happen so that they
understand what's expected of them
numbers from this past workshop that we
just ran so we had 30 students six
coaches so we got that nice ratio every
single one of the students surveyed said
that they would come to another user
group meeting awesome and we had 64 new
members join our meetup our user group
so it was a 25-percent group increase in
less than a month and I really like this
is the stuff that our students said
about us my favorite one is actually a
difficulty level one that since remember
javascript is a special snowflake
there's plenty of places you can go and
run through like Vera turtle equals cat
on the internet and your console or
whatever but there's not a lot of places
that'll really explain to you like this
is what the concept of a variable means
and this is why it matters and here's
how the object literal is related to the
Dom ability to talk to coaches it's
another favorite that's why one of the
reasons why they're so important
election hands-on and pans on is always
really important I always do try to talk
my maximum kind of talking is about 15
minutes that's like the most all talk
before I let people get on their
computers and do stuff it could be just
as like just make something up and be
like I want you to make an array and
fill it with animals and then they'll do
it and low you know and you'll find out
really quickly if they understand what
an array is and how they populated with
uh with Donna so so you can do it too so
how do you run a workshop you people
here who love education and want to
bring it to your user group so you can
try it yourself
because i put the curriculum that we
used in philly line at j s for everyone
on my github and so it consists of it's
a reveal presentation like this one so
it's actually so if you know remember
how our veal presentation is like you
can make the detection so the vertical
sections are split like that and so
their components so theoretically when I
do it is 30 minutes per component once
you in like that's including interactive
time that's not just talking time so
coming over these are the very very
basic JavaScript fundamentals that we go
over big thing in front of mel's course
be really kind and sincere don't assume
that anyone knows everything the reason
they're in your workshop is because they
want you to explain it to them kindly
and with sincerity so go slowly be kind
and honestly and sincerely explain
things like what an object literal is so
some tips for you guys if you're
interested in this thang I promised a
lot in my in my talk so I'm running
through a lot so how I teach and coach
watch the room so like for example right
now this is late in the day so this is
really difficult because a lot of you
are looking at your computers so if I
were teaching this that's a class I
would probably make you all do something
so and also when you're teaching and
coaching listen more than you talk it's
definitely obviously important for a
coach but a lot of people we get so
excited that we want to talk a lot but
we really need to not and let them tell
us what's going on seriously by
listening more than you talk you prevent
a lot of confusion and you help solve
any confusions for the student a lot
faster so asking for clarification
rather than doing some exposition is
generally what you want to do so give
space the thing about don't touch the
keyboard that's physical space also give
kind of emotional space so if someone
I've seem like it's hard and remember
that these are adults so like the thing
about teaching adults is like they don't
have to be there and they can bail at
any time but theoretically they came
because they want to be there so your
job is to kind of help them want to be
there if that makes sense so given an
emotional space like if they are getting
frustrated and like see people get like
really upset and don't say things
like you're doing fine that seems like
an awesome thing to say not something to
say because then their head goes oh my
god I'm a terrible person I'll never
ever know JavaScript saying things like
well tell me more about it have we
looked at this part of it do you want to
look at that part of it with that help
like be more like that and like
recognizing the problem rather than
trying to sidestep the problem and
embrace your style so this is one of the
tips that someone gave me about when I
started teaching is that if you want to
do all your lectures with cat pictures
awesome um kind of just embracing the
way you want to talk because when you
teach especially if you're comfortable
it helps the people in front of you be
comfortable they can feel if you're
nervous and if you just run I want to
run away then that might that make them
feel that way too but you can't do it
wrong or you will find out very quickly
if you are because they will leave
that's not the nice way to say it but
that's true so I have not always been
the best teacher and I've had people get
really frustrated and so that I figured
it out and then I figured out what I was
doing wrong so that's just kind of a
caution in case it sounds like a lot to
do but really like giving you a try and
then you can figure it out is the way to
go so one of my favorite things that the
Boston Python workshop says is they say
when when we're teaching a workshop like
well and filius a PI star workshop but
we use Boston Python curriculum but we
say today is not as important as
tomorrow today is not as important to us
tomorrow so the workshop is not as
important as the day after in the day
after that whatever you do when you're
learning something doesn't matter if you
don't use it so one of the best things
you can do is that's why having these
things in a user group is really great
because you already have and an
organization to attach things onto so
the classic user group meeting with
talks we generally try to have a more we
usually we do talk meetings every other
month and philly and we have two talks
one talks more like a kind of intro talk
it might be an intro to certain
technology and the other one's a little
bit more advanced that's kind of help me
run it
having lightning talks we also combine
our lightning talks with project nice
project nights are what some people call
hack nights we call them project nights
because they make them more accessible
to everyone a lot of people have your
new to development especially don't
really understand the idea of a hacker
and like they think of like you know the
you know black screen max breaking into
the Department of Defense cut thing they
don't really get that you know hackers
people working on things so we do
project night and lightning talks for us
our lightning talks 45 minutes some
people do longer lightning talks I talks
are a great way to get your new members
to start talking to people quickly I've
even had workshop attendees give a
lightning talk at the next session
because they just want to talk about a
problem they solved using something cool
that they learn and it will be valuable
to someone there and no matter what it's
only five minutes so it's a really
accessible way for people to get started
and book clubs or providing other ways
for people to get in contact with each
other whatever works for your group we
lean on meetup com a lot it works for us
you use what works for you so summary is
put your education into your user group
because by doing that hopefully we can
make a better community in order to make
a better JavaScript making better
JavaScript errs and bring the joy to the
masses through education thank you
you